one of the nation's leading authorities
on autism is out with a new book
offering advice on working with young
people with autism one in 54 children is
diagnosed with an autism spectrum
disorder in this country 1 in 54 and of
those between 24 and 40 percent are
considered to be non-verbal well jamie
wax went to colorado to meet with the
book's author temple grandin who was
once told she would never be able to
speak jamie good morning good morning
tony that's right as you'll see she did
learn to speak write teach and so much
more temple grandin has a phd is a
university professor and is considered
an expert in many more than one fields i
met with her at the temple grandin
equine center in colorado state
university where she told me it's
important to expose those on the
spectrum to the world
i always make sure i'm introduced as
temple grand and professor of animal
science i think that's important that i
have a real job
temple grandin has split her life
between understanding animals and
helping explain autism you consider
autism a gift in the milder forms it can
give you some real advantages but in the
milder forms you get a brain that's more
thinking
rather than a brain that's more social
emotional
being social emotional eats up a ton of
processor space in the brain my name is
temple grandin as the hbo film about her
details her brain works differently she
thinks in pictures
can you bring everything you've seen to
your mind
sure
even if it were
an everyday object like
say shoes
i see all shoes i've worn my mothers and
other people i've met and you have three
pairs one is a new heel you know she's
in newspaper ads and tv ads
[Music]
it's a feature of her autism that has
helped her understand animal behavior my
work with cattle the first thing i did
was to get down in the chutes to see
what cattle were seeing as i noticed
that cattle would you know slime stop
and refuse to move through a chute and i
noticed that maybe there's a coat on the
fence a piece of chain hanging down and
other people didn't notice those things
at the time you discovered all of these
things you were having trouble relating
to other human beings but you related
well to animals why do you think that
well i think it related to animals
because they don't think in words they
think in pictures
you've seen a lot of breakthroughs with
autistic people in these animals
absolutely i've had parents tell me that
their kid did their first words on a
horse wow and this would be mostly
younger children
the 74 year old is the co-author of 11
books on autism her latest navigating
autism nine mindsets for helping kids on
the spectrum encourages seeing autistic
children as more than just their
diagnosis it's a very interesting
approach to break this down into
mindsets where did that come from well
it came from the idea of not having them
locked into the label let's look at
other medical conditions that are
commonly associated with autism you take
them into the regular doctor and say
well he's just pitching a fit because he
has autism
well maybe he's having behavior problems
because his stomach hurts
and that needs to be treated
it's interesting to me because as the
parent of an autistic child in many ways
i feel like my daughter is born in the
best time in history to have autism well
when i was a child the individuals with
autism either had no speech delay or
maybe a very slight speech delay they
would usually get out and get jobs and
and do stuff kids like me i was really
severe looking at age three and what was
usually done with kids like me in the
50s is put us in an institution today
things are so much better there's just
no comparison but where we're falling
down is with the older fully verbal kid
making that transition from the world of
school to the world of work
grandin says schools are not putting
enough emphasis on hands-on training
vocations where autistic children can
excel students get interested in things
they get exposed to and so you should
expose them to his broader well i'm a
big fan of exposing them to many things
and people ask me all the time what
would you do if you could change the
schools i want to put all the hands-on
classes back in
art sewing cooking woodworking theater
music there's a lot of kids that are
kind of different that aren't getting
exposed to the things that they could
turn into a career i had a girl in my
class last semester who had never used a
ruler they just don't have any idea
where anything comes from do you think
the pandemic in going virtual made that
even worse well it certainly didn't help
at any but
i also learned that having a good online
class is a lot more work than
than in person class
because you have to do the discussion
boards and to do those well it's a ton
of work
i have to ask you and i i i'm gonna try
not to get emotional about it but
um
you are the person
who allowed me
to see it to see inside my child's mind
well good and to help her
what does it mean to you
that i'm one of millions of people well
it really means a lot to me when someone
says that my book or something i said
helped
help the parent understand their kid and
that's what i like to hear
i should have known i was sunk as soon
as i said i'm going to try not to get
emotional but uh really she has been
such a revelation for myself millions of
other people connected to the autism
spectrum and one of my very best friends
andy murlis who produced this piece who
also is the father of an autistic
daughter
and
her book
navigating autism is out and on sale now
and is really a great resource wow who
was the person that helped her because
she grew up in a time like she said
where you could be taken to an
institution her mother uh her mother she
would have been taken from her family
and never have seen her mother again and
her mother would not allow that to
happen in fact to the peril of her
parents marriage she disagreed so much
with uh with what her father wanted to
do it's a it's an incredible story of
advocacy before we even know what the
spectrum was you said um during the
commercial break that temple feels like
we are leaning on technology a little
bit too much when it comes to kids yeah
she thinks she thinks autistic is like
video games and screens
are are very dangerous for autistic kids
right now and and using that as a sort
of babysitter which i think a lot of
parents
are guilty of sometimes uh is is very
bad for kids on the spectrum yeah
babysitter press play we call it my
hustle that's right i understand the
story well done yeah jamie thank you
story well done thanks so much and uh if
you want to hear more of jamie's
conversation with temple grandin you can
on today's cbs mornings podcast
next we'll take a look back at all that
mattered this week we'll be right back
[Music]